So let's see how do we access the magnetic disks
and how long does it take to get to our data?
We will assume that the disk is already spinning. If
the disk is not spinning it takes possibly several seconds to
actually spin up the disks. So most of the time
if you're accessing the data frequently, the disk would just keep
spinning. So if the disk is spinning then the axis
time consists of the seek time, which is the time it
takes to move the head assembly to the correct cylinder for our data. So we know
where the data is, we know which cylinder,
which sector, which surface. We first have to get
the heads so that they are above the
correct cylinder. So at that point, one of the
heads will be above the track where our
data really is. Next, there is the rotational latency.
After we have moved the heads, they're somewhere
along the track, but not necessarily, and usually
not, above the very sector that we are
interested in. So the rotational latency is about waiting
for the start of our sector to finally
get under the head that will read it. Note
that the head is actually sitting in one
place at this point, but the platter is rotating
so different parts of the track are getting
under the head and the rotational latency's how long
until the beginning of our sector gets under the
head. Next we have the data read which is,
we read until the end to the sector is
seen by the head. Again the data read really
depends on how fast a disk is spinning and
how many sectors we have per track. For example,
if the whole track is just one sector, then
the data read will be a whole rotation of the
disk. If we have ten sectors per track, then
the data read will be one-tenth of a rotation. Then
there is some controller time for the disk controller
to actually check the check sound, determine that the sector
is okay, and so on. And the IO bus time
which is once the disk drive itself and its controller
have the data, how long does it take
to actually get that data to the main memory?
Now note that unlike a cache or a DRAM
where we could actually be doing multiple axises potentially
at the same time, on a magnetic disk once
we seek to one track we cannot really be
reading other tracks. So really what happens is accesses
to the disk are happening one at a time.
We go to a track, possibly read several
sectors, but we cannot access another track until we
are done with this one and move to the next track. So all of this is the
latency to do one disk access and often
times the latency of a disk request made by
the operating system includes this, plus a significant
queuing delay because we first have to wait for
previous accesses to finish doing this and only then our access can move
the heads to the correct position and do a read or a write.